نبداها بحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث قالت
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في العاصمه
كييف انه هجوما روسيا بصواريخ كروز استهدف
المدينه وان الدفاعات الجويه تمكنت من
تدمير جميع الصواريخ واوضحت الاداره
العسكريه ان الهجوم هو الثالث عشر من نوعه
الذي يستهدف العاصمه من اجواء بحر قزوين
من جانبه طالب رئيس الاداره العسكريه
بالهدوء واتخاذ اجراءات السلامه بتزامن مع
تقارير اعلاميه عن دوي انفجارات في
المدينه
قال رئيس الاداره العسكريه فيدنيبرو ان
منظومات الدفاع الاوكرانيه اسقطت خمسه
صواريخ وسته سيارات من نوع شاهد خلال هجوم
روسي على المقاطعه واكد لساك ان الهجوم
تسبب باضرار جسيمه في احدى مؤسسات النقل
وتدمير محطه وقود وتضروري مؤسستين ومنزلين
وسيارات للمواطنين
قالت هيئه الاركان العامه الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه استهدفت سده كارليف
كالقريبه من مدينه افديفيكا التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه شرقي
البلاد يوم امس الخميس باربعه صواريخ من
طراز اس 300 وحضرت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه من وقوع خطر كبير يتمثل في
اغراق المناطق والبلدات المجاوره
معك حسان اذا كيف تتحدث عن هجوم هو الثالث
عشر كيف تبدو العاصمه كيف بعد هذا الهجوم
نعم سهام بالفعل هو الهجوم الثالث عشر منذ
بدايه شهر مايو
وهجمات موسعه مزدوجه قبل قليل افصحت
السلطات الاوكرانيه وتحديدا القوات الجويه
عن حجم هذه الضربه الصاروخيه وبالمسيرات
التي استمرت لاكثر من سبع ساعات طيله هذه
الليله الفائته
وقالت ان سبعه عشره صاروخا وجهت نحو
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من بينها سبع صواريخ
من طراز اس 3 اس 400 وجهت نحو مناطق الشرق
ومنطقه
وعشره صواريخ وجهت نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كييف من طراز
101 اطلقت من فوق بحر قزوين هذه الهجمه
الكبيره بالصواريخ تزامنت مع اطلاق 31
مسيره انتحاريه نحو المناطق الاوكرانيه من
بينها منطقه دينيبرو التي ايضا تعرضت لقصف
بهذه المسايات بشكل مكثف لكن الدفاعات
الجويه تقول انها تصدت لكافه الصواريخ من
طراز مئه وواحد تحديدا اسقطت عشره صواريخ
وكذلك قامت باسقاط 22 او 22 مسيره
انتحاريه وجهت نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذا
التزامن بين اطلاق الصواريخ واطلاق
المسيرات هو نوع جديد واسلوب جديد تنتهجه
القوات الروسيه لتوجيه ضرباتها في محاوله
للتشويش على الدفاعات الجويه
لمحاوله الوصول الى اهداف معينه عبر هذه
الهجمات المكثفه الوتيره تتسارع بشكل واضح
وتتكثف باتجاه المناطق الاوكرانيه
المختلفه وتحديدا باتجاه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف نتحدث عن هجوم صاروخي
وبالمسيرات كل يومين منذ بدايه شهر مايو
ولكن العاصمه الاوكرانيه كنا قد زرنا عدد
من المناطق في الضفه اليمنى الواقعه هنا
خلفي هناك اضرار بسيطه على عدد من المباني
سبع مباني بالتحديد تعرضت اسطح هذه
المباني لاضرار نتيجه تساقط حطام الصواريخ
التي تم اسقاطها في سماء المدينه لكن خلال
الليل سمعنا اصواتا انفجارات قويه للغايه
عبر وخلال عمليات اسقاط هذه الصواريخ كما
تقول الاداره العسكريه في كييف